bonsoir enrico letta merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france on vient
de parler de mario draghi est chargé de
former un nouveau gouvernement le
sauveur de l'italie tel qu'il est
présenté en ce moment mais un
technocrate pur jus bien de retour c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour l'italie selon
vous ont écouté un peu comme les gens
que vous avez interviewé dans la place
du quirinale je pense aussi que c'était
la dernière chance et ses dernières
chances après draghi n'y a que les
élections dans une situation pandémique
très tendues est dans une situation de
crise économique très complexe donc
j'espère qu'il va réussir nous avez
draghi en italie on aura une grande
réputation qui est lié au fait que il ya
huit ans il a changé
en tant que président de la banque
centrale européenne la ligne de
politique monétaire européenne il a même
défié les allemands il les a battus sur
une ligne politique monétaire qui a été
très importante
or l'italie aussi pour le reste de
l'europe donc il a vécu non pas
seulement comme un technocrate ou un
banquier
et quand quelqu'un qui a tenu le drapeau
national et le drapeau un très très haut
très élevé à quoi doit s'attendre
l'italie une politique d'austérité où
c'est à exclure vu le contexte de crise
pandémique de cette crise trouve une
solution qui est différente de celle qui
avait amené d'autres gouvernement
technocratique dans les années 90 il y a
neuf ans la différence est le fait que
dans les autres cas n'y avait que des
coupes à faire c'est à dire il y avait
un problème de faire baisser le déficit
de la dette
cette fois ci le vrai sujet et comment
employer comment bien employer l'argent
européen
c'est un sujet qui touche beaucoup de
pays à la france aussi à l'espagne il ya
beaucoup d'argent européen qui arrive il
faut bien
voyez et fonds employés pour faire à des
bons investissements de la modernisation
du pays
et c'est là et ce sera ça le sujet le
plus important sur lequel reggae attendu
je pense que son expérience sa vision va
aider à trouver les meilleures solutions
quelles alliances on pourrait voir le
jour pour les formations de ce nouveau
gouvernement
ça c'est le point essentiel c'est à dire
on s'est jusqu'à maintenant qu'ils sont
les partis principaux qui vont l'appuyer
dans sa va être le parti démocrate est
fort c'est calme mais on n'a pas très
clair ce que va faire la droite
souverainiste est ce que va faire cinq
étoiles ce sont des heures très con vu
ce parce que il ya la tentative de les
convaincre soirée droite souverainiste
et soirée cinq étoiles a donné le feu
vert au moins au départ du gouvernement
ce serait très important que le
gouvernement partent avec une grosse
base parlementaire en plus du talent et
d'un système parlementaire ça qui me
dans lequel une un gouvernement de
minorité comme aujourd'hui c'est le cas
en porto portugal ou en espagne en
italie c'est très difficile que ça
puisse marcher il faut une majorité
assez claire au parlement pour que ça
marche mais je dois dire que ce
gouvernement a aussi la grande force de
l'appui du président de la république
une autre système d'un système dans
lequel le parlement est au centre
oui mais quand il ya une crise le rôle
du parlement de r&b beaucoup plus
important de ce qui se passe dans la
normalité et le présent de la vie c'est
lui qui a choisi la guise avait été un
peu la même chose dans mon cas avec le
précédent président qui était napolitano
donc le rôle du présent le public est
très important et va être très important
ça explique peut-être justement vous
parlez de ce système italien
l'instabilité chronique politique en
italie où les raisons sont à chercher
ailleurs
non je pense que c'est une instabilité
lié aux institutions en fait que système
parlementaire et un système qui dans
lequel c'est pas très différent de la
quatrième république française à la
phase avec la chose la plus importante
qui a changé par rapport à la ivème
république française et le fait comme et
en europe et donc on fait les choix
ensemble en europe il faut les appliquer
donc à la fin il ya une nécessité de
faire de choix de les appliquer c'est
pour ça que sur parlement qui avait été
élu en 2018 qui était au début un
parlement pas très pro opère aujourd'hui
va donner lieu probablement et ça
prendra place un gouvernement mené par
tragique hier le plus pro européen ma
dernière question propose justement de
l'europe a le plan de relance européen
de 750 milliards il est important
également pour l'italie plus que jamais
je dirais est ce que ça peut sauver le
le pays dans une situation difficile en
ce moment
bon je pense que c'est la clé qui dans
laquelle il est la solution de tous
parce que ce plan effectivement voit
deux pays l'italie et l'espagne qui vont
recevoir la moitié de l'enveloppé totale
et à cet implant donc qui va donner
finalement à l'italie
la possibilité de faire des
investissements ce qui n'a pas été le
cas dans le passé
parce que dans le passé récent à cause
de la crise
on devait faire baisser le déficit et la
dette donc on a fait des coûts des
coupes et on en à employer l'argent qui
était destiné aux investissements pour
les dépenses courantes ce qui ne va pas
se passer maintenant parce que il va y
avoir l'argent européen pour les
investissements dans que je pense que ça
va aider beaucoup ça va aider beaucoup
de relances et je pense que ça va aller
au cou aussi l'europe parce que une
relance italienne va et une fin de
l'instabilité la crise italienne va
aider l'europe
merci beaucoup à neko l'état ancien
président du conseil des ministres
italien président de l'institut jacques
delors d'avoir été avec nous ce soir